cuéntenos Cuáles son esos desafíos que
tendrá que enfrentar Carlos III como
nuevo rey
tiene muchos desafíos Carlos III
algunos internos es decir Inglaterra es
un país que está azotado por la crisis
económica aislado internacionalmente
porque se ha alejado de Europa por el
brexit es un país donde tiene una
pluralidad de razas y de y de
procedencias que hay que integrar dentro
y un país que está desanimado y por
tanto esta ceremonia puede ser a una una
ocasión de que se anime verdad y que
coja un lugar en la en el mundo o sea
Inglaterra es un país que ha sido muy
importante pero que ahora ya no lo era y
esta coronación la visualización en el
mundo entero le puede dar una
oportunidad tiene muchos desafíos uno la
cómo duele Cómo es una comunidad de
Naciones que no se sabe si va a
mantenerse con un nuevo rey de hecho hay
alguna república que ya ha dicho que en
tres años va a suscitar un referéndum
para convertirse en República y no
dependencia del rey de Inglaterra tiene
el problema de Escocia
tiene el problema de la propia familia
real británica con divisiones con
enfrentamientos y con con luchas
internas y la figura de Harry o de
Andrés Los Príncipes pues provoca mucha
inquietud tiene un problema consigo
mismo es decir Carlos como príncipe ha
tenido muchas actividades externas ha
opinado de muchas cosas pero ahora como
rey tendría que estar más callado y no
tomar posición sobre temas que dividen a
la población y tiene un problema consigo
mismo con sus carácter porque en fin
dado la vuelta al mundo la imagen de
Carlos enfadado cuando se manchó los
dedos con tinta o cuando le tenía que
quitar le hicimos una mesa unos papeles
que le estorbaban todo eso tiene que
ganárselo en este periodo a partir de
ahora Carlos
aparte de este sentimiento anti
monárquico en los países que hacen parte
de la comunidad de Naciones Carlos se
enfrenta también una creciente presión
para abolir la monarquía británica allí
dentro del Reino Unido es un tema que
debería preocuparle
no exactamente vamos a ver el Reino
Unido tiene una enorme
vinculación con la monarquía con la
corona porque la corona es parte de su
historia la historia de Inglaterra tiene
que ver con Los Reyes y de hecho
escuchaba esta mañana una periodista
británica decir en Nosotros sabemos
historia de Inglaterra que es historia
de los reyes y las reinas por tanto gran
parte del del pasado y del esplendor de
Inglaterra tiene que ver con Los Reyes
en segundo lugar las encuestas indican
que así como Carlos cuando llegó cuando
fue nombrado
proclamado Rey tenía un aprecio del 42%
eso está subiendo poco a poco está
subiendo la presión en este momento
según alguna encuesta 65% de los
británicos creen que con las monarquía
les va mejor que sin la monarquía por
tanto no es claro evidentemente la voz
crítica la voz negativa va aumentando
pero no es Claro que eso se vaya a
imponer
ahora cómo se verá afectada la
popularidad y también la imagen pública
de la monarquía con este nuevo rey
está haciendo muchos esfuerzos el Rey
Carlos por
borrar una imagen de lejanía o de
frialdad y de hecho por ejemplo ha
tenido un gesto muy
significativo la víspera de la
coronación el y Camila se acercaron a
las gentes que estaban en la calle
haciendo turno para poder ver al día
siguiente el paso de la comitiva se
acercaron a la gente a la calle se está
viendo que cuando el Rey Carlos sale a
la calle la gente empieza a verle ya
como rey es que no es lo mismo ser el
príncipe y de hecho Ahí ustedes en las
cuales la gente le besa la mano o sea
que la existencia de un cambio de figura
ya es rey eso va a provocar que la
acepten más pero al fin en fin él tiene
que luchar contra esa sensación de
lejanía y de frialdad que se ha ganado
en estos años y a propósito de esto que
usted menciona
evolucionará de alguna forma el papel
del jefe de estado que hoy ASUME Carlos
III
sí tiene que tener cuidado insisto
porque un rey es un personaje que está
por encima de la política concreta de
cada día y por encima los partidos y no
puede
inmiscutirse demasiado si lo hace tiene
que hacerlo con discreción sin que se
sepa de manera que influyendo en los
líderes entrevistando con ellos pero que
no trascienda ningún tipo de posición
particular porque hay partidos que
empiezan otra cosa de lo que de lo que
él diga entonces tiene que tener cuidado
insisto cuidado consigo mismo porque ya
siento príncipe en muchas ocasiones tomó
partido en polémicas sobre la
agricultura
sin abonos sobre la arquitectura sobre
la historia de las ciudades y eso tiene
que ahora tiene que frenarlo él no puede
ser como digo parte del debate político